>>Pr. Ndi Okereke-Onyiuke of the Nigerian
Stock Exchange
Hi YouTube this is Ndi Okereke-Onyiuke. I'm
the Chief Executive of the Nigerian Stock
Exchange. I also worked at the New York Stock
Exchange before I came over ot the Nigerian
Stock Exchange. I think one thing that can
be done by companies and countries of the
world and even individuals to make the world
a better place for our loved ones is to care
for one another. If you take somebody along,
there's now way one person can solve the problems
of the world, but you should make it a point
or duty to pull up somebody from the line
up, if you help them reduce the level of poverty.
I do not believe in poverty elevation, I believe
in wealth creation. So by pulling up another
human being, not necessarily somebody from
your family, maybe an old school friend, or
somebody that just needs your help. You try
to help that person by getting them a job,
or getting them education, you are helping
the world. On this endeavor, a place like
Davos. We sit down at the roundtable and say
special things about special countries undeveloped
countries of the world need your help. But
for us as an individual, we make it a point
to pull up another human being to make him,
bring him up to middle class level, from poverty
to middle class. I'm positive when you teach
him how to fish, teach him a trade you ????? then
maybe you become the world leader of tomorrow.
So we have to start as individuals. Then as
companies you have to ensure that your human
resource allocation is taking care of every
facet of life. There are many corporations
who make it a point of doing nothing and play
with it especially women of child bearing
age. I think that that is unfair because it's
not their fault that they were born a woman.
It's really through that stage of life the
world will develop by having women reproduce.
So you can not penalize them in the workplace
because they are reproducing the way God wants
it. So you have to make allowances for women
of child bearing age. Not to discourage their
career because they are meant to have babies.
Let there be flexible work hours, let them
have maternity leave that is paid for no more
than three months. I think that's fair enough.
That should keep the person from lose their
position because they are reproducing for
the world. So women should be empowered. And
somebody like me who has struggled to get
up there, I'm not at the highest level but
as far as I've gotten up, I've tried to help
a lot of other women get into the stock market,
to become stockbrokers, to ???, to even own
their own brokerage firms. Get them license
to own their own brokerage firm. So these
other women who have managed to break through
would pull up another woman, pull up the second
woman, pull up the third woman then we not
have ??? anywhere because even in the board
room where there are maybe 12 people and maybe
four are people are women it would help a
lot. As opposed to you, being the only woman
on that board. Already you talk about issues,
the men tell them, tell you that they're not
???? but if four people are talking about
the same issues, the men will begin to listen.
You can do something as an individual and
as a head of a corporation. Even if you're
not a Chief Executive, you are management,
you can help to pull up other women, because
when you empower a woman, you empower the
whole world. Men tend to be a little selfish,
but women have the big heart. They help everybody,
the ???, their children, friends of their
children. So when you empower a woman, you
empower the whole world. Lastly are the countries
themselves. Well I don't believe in poverty
elevation so I don't ask people to go hand
in hand to the Western World. They've given
us that they give us donations. What I'd rather
do is to have the developed world mentor,
mentor, provide opportunities to mentor people
from the less developed countries so that
they will learn. People like us have been
exposed to Davos. We've learned a lot to rule
the world also help up people so I don't believe
people should hand in hand and give us that.
We must pay for the poor people. We've learned
a lot from this Davos on four occassions.
Of the four people I was priviledged to listen
to, Bill Gates, who has singled handedly helped
do a lot of work in creating wealth through
technology, all over the developed countries
of the world. So if a lot of other people
like Bill Gates were ??? that would do that
it would help the world a lot. So wherever
you are don't go hand in hand begging for
a plan because it won't last two or three
days. What you should do is get people, people
like me, to help you in technical ways where
you can help yourself create wealth for yourself
and also it will trickle down to others. So
it's a simple world that we have to live in,
so we have to help one another. Because if
your not good by yourself and you have all
that money, you will actually imprison yourself.
You really can't enjoy the money when everyone
around you is poor. So you have to pull up
people for you to be able to enjoy the money.
I'm not saying everybody in the world is to
meant to be equally rich, but want a comfortable
world where the rich and the not so rich will
exist. We don't want too rich or too poor
so must try to level up and it's only in a
place like Davos where the world leaders assemble
every year, that's a place you can for ???. I
believe that as time goes on you will begin
to see the benefits of this assembly in Davos.
Thank you very much.